okay hello everybody
long time no see I'm back again for a
game against -18 felt like giving myself
a little bit of a challenge today but I
think I'm gonna get him I have a good
feeling about this one
so let's let's go before it was for the
Sicilian ye6 wow I don't remember which
Sicilian I was playing that's started
with 2e6
okay 97 Wow why this against sure but I
think I was I think I was 17 at the time
not 18 but that's not picking
to be honest I'm pretty healthy about
the line he chose it's not it's not the
most challenging the Queen goes in the
center but I'm not sure what you're
doing there okay people now I got a
choice do I want to play arena
aggressively with roca three Bishop e3
rook coming to age three am I going to
take extra care considering I got a semi
intelligent opponent there are other
tempting options as well like 92-93
maybe h5 looks safer no I'm not supposed
to play sort of anti silicon beasts
chest but what can you do it's not
always easy to be brave g6 okay it's a
bit of a concession now unfortunately I
lack a bit of the attacking instincts of
some other players I mean I want to go
at five just neither b5 Queen h3 but
it's very hard for me to tell whether
that just gives a very strong attack or
but then again you only live once
okay now defy was going maybe I didn't
do this so cleverly but I got a feel
that I have some serious attacking
potential here still guy has a brain the
last guy into play ah this is screaming
out for some sack okay so one thing I'm
thinking about this c4 then probably
Bishop d7 let's go that's to us I wanted
to get it four squares
maybe my position just isn't like that
good I don't want to start playing
positionally hair but I don't know what
to trace now you go Bishop e3 he
probably takes the pawn on p2 and queen
h6 threatening FGM but yes 94 any sort
of queen sac doesn't look very promising
so I can go tonight h5 I can prepare it
with wicked III I'm not quite sure how
I'm breaking through okay I'll try it
yeah we gotta go for it okay that was
actually expected so I thought I'd just
take back and bond oh [ __ ] yes queen of
two but we'll get three maybe it's not
the disaster we have to must be coming
Oh 21 is also possible but then again
repeat to melt we need to guess overcast
rate we need to as expected tribal chief
I'll just take some pizza that's just
disgusting absolutely disgusting
yeah it feels like I'm wearing short
animation f6
when you 400g three I have to try to
list King h8 so now I at least have
Queen f7 then root g8 junco Bishop h6
first what's the story then fish by six
going on seven clear [ __ ] didn't realize
Bishop g7 ripped your 7f g7 Bishop g7 as
possible those damned wrong moves
just go to fades king is coming to g5
that there's no perpetual then if h4
takes with you seven yes Queen e1 fall
back when you 5h4 try book cheese 710
Bishop a schwa chief by the point is
virtue 721 King edge to it when you five
mig-3 but alas neither -18 or I wouldn't
have fallen for that at that age and the
Machine refers representation of me at
that age certainly
yeah this is over okay thank you
yeah it seems like you need to work anew
on those chess skills yeah
we'll try again next time until then
thank you